- You know when you look at
something that looks hard,
that was probably easy.
And I had this firm belief,
which I still believe,
that people are basically good.
Don't take no for an answer,
when people out there are
giving you advice and saying,
"No this will never work."
If you're passionate about
something and you work hard,
then I think you'll be successful.
Code does change the world and
it can change people's lives.
If somebody does something nice
for you, wouldn't it be nice
in this world if we could
actually start recognizing that.
I think we've lost a
lot of that in America,
it's something that here in Europe
we're a lot more familiar with.
There are no entrepreneurs
out there that are more
hard working and innovative
than the small business.
I didn't sit down and say,
"Hey I'm going to be innovative today."
And if I say that you should treat people
with the benefit of
the doubt, it's because
I believe in that as a way of life.
- He's a French born American entrepreneur
and philanthropist.
He's the founder of eBay,
where he also served
as Chairman from 1998 to 2015.
He has an estimated net
worth of 7.2 billion dollars.
He's Pierre Omidyar, and
here's my take on his
top ten rules for success.
- When you look at the
accomplishments of accomplished
people and you say, "Boy that
must have been really hard,"
when you look at
something that looks hard,
that was probably easy, and
conversely, when you look
at something that looks
easy, that was probably hard.
And so you're never going to
know which is which until you
actually go and do it,
so just do and do it,
try, learn from it, you'll
fail at some things,
but that's a learning
experience that you need
so that you can take that
on to the next experience.
And don't let people who
you may respect and who you
believe know what they're
talking about, don't let them
tell you it can't be done
because often they will
and it's just cause they
don't have the courage to try it.
I started this just with
the idea of, let's bring the
power of interactive technology,
the web, to ordinary people.
And I had this firm belief,
which I still believe,
that people are basically good.
And as I said, if you treat
them well and you treat them
with the benefit of the doubt,
you're not going to be disappointed.
And in the modern world,
we're bombarded with
negative images all the
time about how bad the
world is, how dangerous the world is,
and it is true there are some
dangerous things going on
and there are some bad actors out there
but the majority of
people out there are just
good, decent, honest people.
There's something about
an entrepreneur that is
somewhat sort of anti-establishment,
somewhat disrespectful
of the previous generation
and although that can
grate people the wrong way a little bit,
that a really important element actually.
You need to be passionate
about what you want to work on,
and don't take no for an
answer when people out there
are giving you advice and saying,
"No, this will never work."
I mean you look at eBay,
the idea that in 1995
that you could create
something over the internet
which is this brand new
thing that nobody was really
using at the time, except
for scientists and academics,
and it would be a place where
strangers could actually
do business with one
another, could actually
exchange merchandise for
money without ever meeting,
and the notion that people
can actually buy and sell cars
over the internet, that's crazy right?
Yeah, it's totally crazy.
In fact, lots and lots of people
told me that was crazy.
And I didn't...
I have to say, I didn't have this vision,
"Oh it's going to take over
the world, it's going to
be this fantastic thing overnight."
I didn't have that kind
of delusion either,
but I did say, "You know what, there's
"something worth trying
here, it's not crazy."
I say that you should pursue your passion,
if you're passionate about
something and you work hard,
then I think you'll be successful.
If you start a business because you think
you're going to make a lot of money at it,
then you probably won't be successful,
because that's the wrong
reason to start a business.
You have to really believe
in what you're doing,
be passionate enough
about it so that you will
put in the hours and the
hard work that it takes
to actually succeed there,
then you'll be successful.
- I know I've heard the story
that the first line of code
that you wrote was in an
apartment in Campbell,
not too far from here.
- That's right, just down
the street, that's right.
- I mean, did you have
any idea, you wrote this,
you put it out on the internet...
- Yeah.
- You didn't sort of do it thinking,
"Hey, I'm going to build an
83 billion dollar business."
- No, of course not at all, not at all.
Really it was just this, as I said,
as a software engineer,
I wanted to write some
tools that I thought
could be useful to ordinary
people, regular people.
I had a day job,
it started as a nights
and weekends project,
and it's amazing,
of course now we all understand,
code does change the world
and it can change people's
lives, but I think what makes
eBay unique, despite the
fact that there are many...
Sort of now there are more
marketplace businesses
out there, we are really,
have always been about people,
it's always been about bringing
tools to ordinary people,
and giving them the tools
and the opportunities that
they need, that they can
use to then be successful,
and define success in their own way.
So yeah, those early weeks
and months were crazy.
So I remember one of the
very first items listed,
this was in 1995, in September of 1995,
one of the very first items listed was a
1952 Silver Dawn Royals Royce,
and the seller, and I wish
we could find the seller,
the seller was amazing
because he or she had done
this beautiful listing,
and so you could put html
in there, the seller had
created a server somewhere
to actually host photos,
back in those days you had to
actually run your own
server to host photos,
and actually had this
beautiful listing on there.
I looked at that and I
said, "This is incredible,
there is no way anyone will
ever buy a car on the internet"
Like that's just ridiculous,
that'll never happen.
(audience laughter)
Of course now, there's a
car sold every four minutes,
on a mobile device, it's incredible,
it's totally incredible.
So who could've imagined that.
It was actually in February of '96,
I came up with the idea of
creating the feedback forum.
And basically what that
was, was to encourage people
to give each other feedback based on
how did their transaction go.
And since I was getting
all these complaints,
I assumed that it would
be mostly negative,
that it was a forum to give
each other negative feedback.
And so I wrote this little
letter, to the community,
in February of '96 announcing
the feedback forum,
and I basically in it I
said, "Hey listen, people are
"basically good, we all
try to good a good job,
"we all try to do our
best, but sometimes things
"don't work out, it would be
great, let's give each other
"the benefit of the doubt,
but if you're having real
"problems with somebody, now
there's a feedback forum."
Basically you don't
have to complain to me,
but there's a feedback forum.
"If your complaint is worthy of complaint,
"then you should do it
publicly and complain in a
"public forum, but while
you're at it also think about
"giving praise where praise
is due. If somebody does
"something nice for you,
wouldn't it be nice in this
"world if we could actually
start recognizing that,
"and let's give each other
praise where praise is due."
And we found that when you
give somebody the opportunity
to give praise, to give
positive feedback when
it's well deserved,
people love to do that,
it's very gratifying
yourself to be able to give
praise too, to somebody else.
So anyways, the feedback
forum was just a remarkable,
incredibly gratifying
testament to human nature
and the fundamental
goodness of human nature.
But then also, from a
business perspective,
it was really the thing that
allowed eBay to succeed,
because it gave people a
chance, a way to know that
they could actually trust
a complete stranger.
What I realized through the
eBay experience was that
people are hungry for
personal communication
and personal relationships
around a shared area of interest.
And I received hundreds of
letters, thousands of letter,
from eBay users that
say, "You know, eBay has
restored my faith in humanity,
I've met my best friends on eBay."
There are people that have been married
that have met on eBay.
It's a little bit strange,
it's definitely not the
majority of the users, but
there's something special
going on there, and I think
what it is, is when you give
people a forum in which to
communicate and communicate
around a shared area of
interest, no matter what
socioeconomic classes they
come from, what neighborhoods
they come from, or
geographies, they realize that
they're human beings and
they realize that they
can be a community today.
So what we want to do with
our philanthropy is to just
help people rediscover
that, especially in America,
I think we've lost a
lot of that in America.
It's something that here
in Europe, we're a lot more
familiar with, we're a lot
more comfortable with a notion
of an individual being a
part of a community and
having a responsibility to
be a part of that community.
In America, through a variety
of reasons that I won't
go into, I have some thoughts
on it, people have become
isolated, people are
afraid to talk to their
neighbors sometimes, but
at the core people do want
to be part of a community
and all we have to do now
is figure out how to
rekindle that a little bit
and that's our mission.
I'm young, I'm 33 years old,
my wife and I are 33 years old,
we've got at least 50 good years
ahead of us to work on this,
and it's going to be a lifetime pursuit.
There are no entrepreneurs
out there that are more
hardworking and innovative
than the small business owner.
I mean like give me a break.
(audience applause)
So Silicon Valley, look at
these wonderful entrepreneurs,
and of course, we all work
really hard in Silicon Valley,
here as well, but it is really
hard to run a small business,
even though eBay's growth was very fast.
In those early days I learned some of
the difficulties myself, as an individual,
just having to deal with all that.
That, for me, is true entrepreneurship.
Now what people here in
Silicon Valley also do,
is we have this incredible sense of vision
of what's possible in the
world, and I think to be
a successful entrepreneur
you have to have also
a little bit of self delusion in your own
ability to make that happen.
I didn't sit down and say,
"Hey, I'm going to be innovative today."
It was really trying to
experiment with new tools.
I'm a software engineer so
I'm basically the latest,
coolest, shiny toy at
the time was the web,
was interactivity, and the way I expressed
my creativity was through writing code.
Fast forward to Labor Day weekend of 1995,
I sat down at my computer and
I started writing a script,
a purled script, to create a
very basic auction mechanism.
The code was really simple,
it allowed you to list an item
for sale, have a title
and a description, and a
starting price, and you
could also see a list of all
the items that were listed,
obviously that was important,
and then you could bid on an item.
If you think about the retail environment,
where people are buying things
in a retail environment,
the retailer has a whole bunch of control.
They choose the products,
they design the store
or the catalog, if they
train the salespeople,
they control the experience,
and if there's a problem
with a salesperson they
retrain and so on and so forth.
At eBay, our customer's
experience is based on how one
customer interacts with
another customer, and you
can't control customer
behavior, so the only thing
you can do is have a certain set of values
that you encourage people
to adopt, and the only way
your customers are going
to adopt those values
is if they see you living
those values as well.
So when I say that I believe
people are basically good,
it's because I believe
it's not something that
I came up with for eBay.
And if I say that you
should treat people with the
benefit of the doubt, it's
because I believe in that as
a way of life and we have
to do it internally at eBay
at the company as well,
because if we don't then
eventually that seeps through
and customers will see that,
and that will harm our business
because we can't control
customer behavior, so our
business is based on that.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Mortesa Dariani asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Pierre's top ten rules
hit you the hardest,
meant the most to you,
leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.